first of all as I said in New York and I
will say again on camera love this movie
I want to say congratulations start
let's just start with that the thing
that a lot of people won't realize is
that this movie has been in development
for since cinema began in the early
hours it was a result right exactly but
I think it's it's amazing that this
thing finally got made just because of
how much time has been put in can you
sort of talk about the very very
beginning of this and how many actors
it's a who's who of Hollywood that's
been attached to this movie well there's
there's been definitely a lot of actors
who were attacked very talented people
and there was also you know others that
have shown interest but didn't actually
formally attach so but it has been a
magnet though for sure it's always
attracted very very talented people on
both sides of the camera it's been very
fortunate it initially came to Atlas by
a cast reveal of Mark Boal well they
were in post-production on Hurt Locker
they had an idea for this movie and Hurt
Locker as you know was done completely
independent and they wanted to try their
hand and make it a studio deal and I was
helpful in them making setting the props
I was helpful in setting the project up
at to impairment and that wasn't 2009 or
2010 2000 that were you working for me
then I was I was actually the project I
started so long ago I was an assistant
on are you at the time and yeah finally
got made it just precedes the Oscar
season where her lager won all the
awards is that it which is free was no
script
there was no script at that time the
script came in after
I'm very curious did it ever in the
development process how because if I'm
not mistaken it came close to actually
going before yes and then it didn't
so can you sort of talk about that part
of because I think it's fascinating to
for the history of this movie because
it's such an unusual track to get a made
well I think the number of times it
almost got made is what makes it so
unusual but really talented people
attaching and for whatever reason it not
working out and then detaching and
others attaching that's a pretty
commonplace thing but in this situation
back then we had discussions you know
with a lot of really great actors who we
chatted with the first real attachment
though was Tom Hanks Tom Hanks was
attached to play read fly
you know I'm version of read yeah that
version of read fly and he would play
the red fly character back when Kathryn
and Wizkid of directed and Mark you know
it was Marcus print that he developed
with her we developed together at
Paramount I'm curious
it's easy what for you guys as a company
what was it about the material because
it's eating I'm sure you see all these
scripts that come through and there's
all these different possibilities of
what you can spend your time on what was
it about this material that said that
you kept trying to lift it up and get it
made because it's a great story an
elevated nice movie a heist movie that
makes you that is about something about
guys who have you know who have a reason
that you can relate to in terms of why
they're motivated to pursue this so it
was a smart elevated and kind of
character driven heist
I think that always attracted us and we
always thought it was worth pushing
forward and also I think as as Alex said
part of its uniqueness was the fact that
you know when you're dealing with Delta
Force guys you're dealing with the best
of the best
right in the sense that you've heard of
Army Rangers you're heard of Navy SEALs
you've heard of Green Berets in order to
be Delta Force your entryway to possibly
being Delta Force is you have to be one
of those guys if you're not one of those
guys or yeah and now they have a few
women as well but if you aren't one of
that group you can't even begin to
audition for Delta Force so these are
truly the best of the best and having
spent their career being that the idea
that they might use those skills for
themselves is an intriguing idea I was
gonna say uh through the development
process I would imagine there's many
versions of the script I know JC when he
came on he tweeted stuff how was there
ever a radically different version of
this movie or was it always about the
heist and what comes after I think it
stayed the same I mean Andy yeah the
movie is always tickety's I think it was
incremental changes over years yeah yeah
and I think the the concept of the movie
which essentially is a bunch of
characters that have a very special set
of skills and all of a sudden they find
themselves in everyday life with no use
of those skills and a lot in seeing them
be able to sort of use those skills for
their own benefit for the first time and
see the repercussions of that those
ideas were always in the industry they
would always sort of the essence of the
movie from from day one
I think what what what the difference in
what Mark wrote and what JC changed or
augmented was that the different
characters had you know may have gone
into a slightly different job there the
their families or lack of families may
be slightly different but that you know
was more in terms of the character
definition that in terms of the plot but
it didn't form the plot there's
obviously character does inform the plot
and some of the consequences evolved and
changed and locations evolved what you
know specifics like what the what
Laureus house looked like and how Lauria
you know was set up those kind of things
changed over time and and and also you
know where characters end up in the
story completely check and ulaana's
character really changed I actually know
that I think about yeah I'm a big fan of
what Netflix has been doing and I think
that the trajectory of the quality of
movies they're making has been on a
steady upward stream including triple
frontier talk a little bit about
collaborating with them and just how I
guess what was that initial how did it
first get to Netflix and how quickly did
the jump on it yes sir I mean when when
we hit a place that at Paramount where
the movie it was clear of the movie was
not going to continue there and they
were having a change of executives and
it just you know that happens sometimes
it just wasn't clicking we looked around
at the at the landscape and and and and
and looked at where potentially we could
continue like you said we weren't gonna
give up on it right we really believed
in it and looked at the potential
players and and Netflix emerged from a
number of conversations because there
were a number of places interested as
the but best place to move forward and
keep our momentum going and the
experience was great I mean I have to
say that from from production and
continued belief in the movie through
you know how strong their marketing and
publicity was it was a pretty great
experience they really stood there with
us and believed in the movie and I think
the you know the idea of us looking for
a new home for the movie I think
coincided with I think was the same week
that Scott Stewart took over I wasn't
even in his office yet yeah I remember
the email that came from I thinking it
wasn't even a Netflix email address at
that point because he had hadn't moved
officially into his office in Netflix so
it was that early and it just was was
perfect timing he was a fan of JC was a
fan of the project and what it was and
I'm always curious with with a lot of
the studio look if this was released
let's just arbitrarily say about Warner
Brothers you're gonna have test
screenings you might have a focus group
you're gonna there's certain things but
obviously happen is it different at
Netflix when you're making a movie we
don't we did the same thing the same
process same process and prepping a
movie the same process and what the
creative vision that all the department
heads have it's in process and finishing
a movie in terms of testing a film so
really in terms of doing a temple film
that is at a major studio and Netflix
there's there's no difference in the
making of it but what is interesting and
different his bid is how they evaluate
what the product should be in other
words we did make with Netflix the fully
robust the version of the movie we
really and JC really wanted to make
meaning all the bells and whistles and
toys to really execute the action cast
and pop the way we dreamed about casting
it up and I think how they analyzed
those decisions is a little bit
different than a theatrical studio and
you also have the you know when you're
doing a temporal sense film in a studio
you have a release date that you're
backing your way into usually so that
pressure and that that time constraint
is always sort of sitting in the back of
your mind
you know with Netflix I think we didn't
have an exact date in terms of when they
were gonna release we knew the window we
do they want me to talk with ya but we
but that pressure I'm sort of backing
your way and do a very specific date and
rushing to get the movie out there by a
certain time didn't we didn't feel that
pressure as much analysis we have I'm
always curious about the editing room
because that's the final rewrite how is
it how was it for the editing I would
say the final mix is the final rewrite
okay that's very true but you know what
I mean like there's big changes that can
happen in the editing room where are
there big changes in the editing room on
this film and how does the test
screening scores and what the test
screening is telling you mixed with the
analytical data that Netflix provides
how does that alchemy come together in
the editing room that might be different
than something somewhere else that's a
great question from the standpoint of
giving you the analysis of the test
screening it's very very much similar to
what we've all become accustomed to of
test screenings whether their friends
and family sweetings or they're
recruited screenings with cards with
cards with numbers it's almost exactly
the same as was the process with a
studio and and we all learn from it you
know JC the editors are you know you
guys are talking to right now we all
learn from that and we give our opinions
and and we all interpret the data
sometimes the same sometimes generally
but it was extremely helpful and the had
Netflix functioned in very much the same
way a really good collaborative studio
best yeah and I said change of course
yeah I'm curious how things alter in the
editing room because getting honestly we
did
think we did one day of additional
photography it actually it actually
wasn't in search we did a half-day I
mean search it's outside of that no
reshoots no yeah but you learn things
about like shape to me the thing that
changed the most over the editorial
process was really the shaping of the
characters right because we have we have
good guys
doing a bad thing for the wrong reason
and so tracking the empathy or the route
ability right that was really the the
tricky part of the of the editorial
process and and of course they start out
being good guys thinking they're doing
something maybe morally ambiguous but
still ultimately a good thing because as
part of the process are gonna be taking
out a really bad guy and and and by
getting the money for themselves they're
also going to make sure that that money
doesn't follow the wrong hands so so for
all those reasons they've talked
themselves into they're actually doing a
right thing you know and so we we have
to just make sure that that came across
so that when they go on this journey you
are actually rooting for them and and
you know and then the evolution of the
story happens so I would say the story
didn't change heartily at all from the
first screening to the last screening it
was clearer and tighter I am a big fan
of guide Norris who is your second unit
on this movie as are we
there's only a few people I mean there's
a lot of second unit directors but
there's a few big guns you know people
that have done big spectacles guy Norris
is one of those people how tough is it
to actually land someone like that
because I would imagine people on that
level are being booked all the time for
really big projects well it wasn't on
this one it wasn't hardly I mean Chuck
stone guy Norris for what 30 30 plus
years like we've all worked with him
before
guys really very close
friend of mine we work together for the
very first time I met him in fact a film
called the saloon of the juggler or the
blood of heroes depending on where the
movie was released sure welcome you by
the way the United States it's edge of
tomorrow or live die repeat it happens
all the tents so exactly so we we bonded
in a wonderful way and I've been making
many movies together since then so that
was in the mid 80s right but it's one
place where the schedule changes that
happen on this movie worked to our
advantage because there was an earlier
iteration where guy wasn't available
yeah and then when we shifted the
production schedule he became available
so sometimes there are silver likes and
and I know JC always wanted guy Norris
for the movie and as Alex said I think
the first version movie wasn't available
but I remember when we were doing
Suicide Squad and JC came out to me yeah
he was very impressed and he watched you
know this incredible action scene and
got to know guy guys one of those people
that he's just he's the best it's a cool
calm and collected at all times you
can't you can't rattle that guy really
he's really at his most precise and
visionary when he's doing a lot of real
live action sucks yeah which is with
cameras which is my part too because
when I spoke to the cast they all talked
about how God wanted in-camera effects
practical onset and I'm curious how that
I don't want to say adds to the
production schedule but how does that
all get worked out because I would
imagine there's certain people that are
saying let's just do this with CGI we
can insert that shot we can do this but
as an audience member
it always is better with practical so
I'm just curious how that as producers
how do you weigh that line of what to do
in in you know in camera and what to add
later we all wanted as long as we could
do it safely to do it as much in camera
as
possible particularly because we're
dealing with you know as we said you
know actors who had conditioned
themselves to get as close as they could
to the real-life thing and we had
real-life consultants who actually were
the real thing there to help us and to
talk with guy and to talk with the great
and make sure that they were you know
ready to exert themselves and they did
you know we had very many interesting
days where they were working in very
practical ways that were very difficult
high in the mountains deep in the mud or
jungle or centipedes or whatever else
would fall ready but there wasn't a
thing that with doing all these
practical stunts that we did we got
killed with rain in Hawaii so what we
weren't just doing them on dirt roads we
were doing them on mud muddy roads and
during rain and sleet and so it was it
was sort of like practical stunts in the
hardest conditions right be giving them
in and so we threw everything we
couldn't the environments through
everything they couldn't guy Norris and
he kind of just ply right there
[ __ ] great job but it's always uh it's
always for me it's a brilliant blend
right it it you start with the practical
it looks like it's practical and then
you do something that is and then the
CGI to just take it to that place that
can't possibly be I'm almost out of time
but I want to do I have some individual
watchman's but I have to do one thing
that because some people in the room
might not have seen the movie had I'm
going to be respectful one of the things
I think is pretty badass about this
movie is the third act how can I say
this delicately uh twist there there is
something that happens in the third act
that a lot of people are not going to
expect I think it's a great decision
that can only probably happen at like a
Netflix because maybe another studio
doesn't let that happen because I've
heard through the grapevine that that
person tried to do it before I'm talking
real vague here what what did you talk a
little about that twist
and you know because I heard it was his
idea I mean I'd maybe I'm wrong we
should all speak to it because we we all
I was a virgin yeah there was always a
version or something like that happened
but not to that particular character and
I think that because of what the movies
about thematically and that it is a
meditation on greed right because greed
is what turns them greed is what changes
them the idea that there's a price paid
for that is very important to the theme
of the movie you guys can add to that so
I think that that informed the impulse
and the actor was game it you know we
played with we'd cut that scene a bunch
of different ways to sort of for maximum
efficiency and then I remember in the
premiere yeah there was an audible gasp
yeah in the room you're gonna give it
away there was a lot of a gasp in the
room and then people were yelling and
screaming it you know at that moment and
I think at that point we all realized
that we found the best version of that
soon oh yes because it wasn't you know
it was a scary scene to cut I've gotten
a lot of feedback young people have seen
it yeah you get a lot the cool thing
about Netflix just the throw it in there
is a I've gotten so much feedback so
quickly since the movies been available
from people all over the place people
who don't have theaters near them it's
kind of cool it's it's amazing and I'm
sure you have no idea how many people
have watched or have they actually told
you know that would tell this no yeah
it's gonna say they think they told us
that they're very happy but they haven't
told us the finish but very happy right
yeah I am sure listen everyone I know
that the work for Netflix they all say
the same thing I have no idea but we
look at like the Google Trends and see
if people are talking about it but we
can't tell you know like they'll never
sharing the data you know so I have a
few individual questions obvious I'll
start with you I'm very curious I've had
a theory as to why the Wonder Woman
release state happened the change and
I'm just curious if it has anything to
do with China it doesn't so what can you
share because rich
was coming out at a point and then I
guess it got pushed back up a number of
months we always wanted the date that we
are on right now the studio felt that
until their slate for the year before
came together and they had an amazing
end of 18 that they needed to have a big
you know what I call aircraft carrier
letterhead pole in that year and they
you know we had a very rushed
pre-production because Patti also did
television TNT movie Sunday all darkened
and we had a very rushed post-production
schedule in order to make the date that
we were on which was November first 19
year and you know we were doing it
because it studio said they really
needed it and then at a certain point
they came to us and they said you know
what you guys are right let's go back to
the month that you guys release wonder
what we want in and take the extra time
because I've heard and maybe I'm wrong
but the what I've heard recently with
China is that they will no longer allow
a different version of the movie to play
in China it now has to be the same
version that gets released in America
for a while that's been true for a while
we faced that on Warcraft we faced that
on a number of yes because I was
wondering if that was something with
good you know you want to make the film
done to have like a damn date with China
the issue with China is black out there
well there's a black out period and
normally a lot of that has to do with
Chinese New Year and things like that so
there's that but the blackout periods
have gotten less it is making sure it's
the same movie there was used to be a
little bit more latitude now they really
want it to be exactly the same movie and
that means you have to finalize it that
way before you show it to them and the
screening period for them is gets longer
or longer where they screen and then
tell you
it can come in and date you all of those
things are true that wasn't the reason
for the push yeah but so my question is
now with the June release date I believe
it's June that so that allows maybe more
of a chance of a day and date around the
world with that movie state well that is
true that is true
yeah and that is a positive that's an
additional positive outcome sure I'm
going to push a little further because
I'm not already out of time but so I
want to know what's going on with
unchartered haha we're working on it
right because you signed a cool director
I'm a big fan of and do you think it can
be in front of cameras this year there's
a shot we're working we're trying for
that okay I'm definitely trying for that
right it's uh I'm so curious about this
movie because it's one of these that's
been in oh yeah
thanks for running us you know I'm just
throwing it out there where we are we
are as passionate about getting
Uncharted minute as we were about triple
frontier and I really believe we will
succeed and I think the studio is
completely on board we have the right
filmmaker and we're working our asses
off to get it there Joe
Carney and I believe wrote a version of
the script I think yeah we've had a
number of talented writers I was gonna
say some easier is it still being worked
on in terms of scripting is this someone
you can share that's writing it we're
we're still working with Dan in terms of
script adjustments but you know but it's
a newer version of the script than the
one you're referencing I know exactly
how it's a completely different
conversion yes I'm it was a read you put
my I got yeah I want to know if but
what's going on with Shane black project
that I believe you were working on as a
destroyer you know we're we're working
on the script with Sonny yeah it's a
project that Chuck and I have a working
off
very very long time it's based on one of
our favorite books syriza's and you know
we're just working on the script we got
to get it right yeah I'm a big fan of
Shane and I need him to make more movies
the talent yeah that's what I have I got
I got a hit stop and I will just say
congratulations on triple frontier
thanks for